another shonen fandom that is like the
little [ __ ] brother is the
seven deadly sins fandom yeah they're
like the little rut you're like
the dude no one gives a [ __ ] about you
stop [ __ ] making noise
dude it's a shame because like i
actually really enjoyed seven deadly
sins i wasn't a fan i didn't give a [ __ ]
about it like yeah
i thought it was pretty like epic turn
your brain off monkey brain don't focus
entertainment yeah it was that perfect
like shonen white noise the way that
i thought the other shonens are a bit
too boring right it's weird because
seven deadly sins is the one shonen that
i've
really really tried to get into yeah i
mean like i i think seven deadly sins
has been the show that i've tried to get
into the most that i just couldn't
i've given it four chances four and i
still can't turn you off trip
just the fact that there wasn't there
wasn't any
like in season one at least because i
haven't gone past season one there
wasn't any doubt
that the the heroes were like that like
meliodas or whoever was on like the
hero's theme would be
true because because in season one the
only threat
to the main characters are the main
characters yeah you know what i mean
and i don't know like i i get that
everyone is so ridiculously overpowered
and that's like kind of the charm of the
series yeah but i just couldn't get past
that point that i'm just like
man why am i watching this fight when i
know that there's not even like a hint
of a threat
like yeah see i didn't even get to that
point like i just look at the seven
deadly sins fan base i'm just like i'm
not putting my foot into that mind
i watched everything up until uh the new
season episode
one then i was like no
and then after that when you saw the
[ __ ] gif like when you saw when you
saw the fight between meliotis yeah
and uh escanor and i'm just like oh if
it feels about to be uh
seven deadly symptoms when i saw the
clip of that on twitter where people
were like this has to be fan manager i
[ __ ]
lost it yeah i lost it but i was also
like i kind of want to watch it
if you don't know seven deadly sins
super popular show and then they handed
it off to which studio was it
i think they handed it off to studio
dean and uh it ended up looking uh like
this
this is one of the stills i know i know
you shouldn't judge the stuff i think
we've talked about this on like the very
first episode no no no we we didn't it's
just from the lost episode
um because i thought like i think i
mentioned something about it it must
suck to be a seven deadly sins
because you just it does at least you
know if you're a dragon ball fan you get
good animation
right like the seven deadly sins anime
we'll just
play like one second of animation here
you go it looks [ __ ] god
you can go onto youtube there's tons of
clips i've just stopped the the entire
meliodas and esquinal fight is [ __ ]
hilarious when i first watched that
episode of see
like season three i think it is uh i was
like just please say psych
like please say like the whole 20
minutes was like please say psych
just yeah just be like now and now it's
time for the real animation
jk this is the animatic i it was like
no no because i i thought it was
good enough right yeah man the fans i
didn't realize how like
out there they were online like they are
like hardcore i didn't know how popular
seven deadly sins was
oh it's really [ __ ] popular yeah yeah
i didn't know how popular it was until
like
i kind of it was kind of the series that
i i thought was just like gonna like
fade into obscurity but then
the more years passed the more popular
it got and the more things i heard about
it and i'm just like
oh i i didn't know where these fans were
when the series started because
maybe i was just [ __ ] blind i didn't
know it was this popular when it started
yeah yeah yeah yeah like easily though
the worst part of seven deadly sins
is the [ __ ] main character no really
i've heard that
i've heard that the entire time because
this this whole character's thing is
like he he i'm op and also i
i i touch women i touch women that's
that's charming and it's like
and it's like i don't know who is this
appealing to because i'm watching this
and i'm like
i'm over the age of 18. and i
like i don't understand who this is
charming to you or clearly to people who
have never touched women in their life
right
i'm just saying yeah i mean i'm sitting
there and i'm literally just like am i
losing my mind or am i the only one who
hates this
because because i remember when i first
watched seven deadly sins i actually
made the tweet
where like i like i remember watching
the first episode and
i remember thinking man what can we do
to give meliodus like a quirky like a
quirky quirk
like the anime quirk let's just uh make
him
accidentally touch women's breasts
leicester molester yeah yeah
yeah and i'm like i'm like you know i'm
not i'm like totally against
culture and everything but i'm just like
it's it's not enough for me to like
turn me off the anime or turn me off
like the entire thing right yeah but at
the same time i'm just like
couldn't you thought of couldn't you
think of something better yeah
again like you said like i'm not all for
being like you can't do that i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ]
but every time it happened on screen it
was like when you got a whiff of a
really disgusting fart you're like
oh yeah yeah it's god really